meteorologist jeff jamison from our cbs  station ktvt is following a new tropical  threat that could impact the u.s jeff  good morning  good morning still tracking major  hurricane irma as it turns off to the  west toward the northeast caribbean  puerto rico hispaniola cuba the bahamas  and the path of the storm as we make our  way toward the end of the week it could  become a category 4 storm a big area of  high pressure is driving this westward  right now eventually we do expect to see  it take that turn to the north but there  is a wide area in the united states that  could be impacted by a landfall from  irma early next week and i'd say  anywhere from the central gulf coast all  the way up to the mid-atlantic needs at  the very least to start preparing for a  hurricane early next week but as time  goes on we'll be able to fine-tune this  forecast quite a bit more but it could  be a major hurricane striking the united  states early next week vlad  jeff thank you very much